also here in Europe but the world around
us keeps spinning we have two bloody
wars continue to rage just outside our
borders the human suffering is immense
and the shocks waves are felt well
beyond Ukraine and Gaza after the energy
and food crisis set off by Russia global
trade is now being disrupted by hooti
Terror in the Red Sea our world is in an
era of Confrontation and conflict of
fragmentation and fear and this moment
calls for focus and responsibility
inside our Union only together can we
address the grave challenges we face and
that is the greatest lesson we have
learned over those four years when we
stand United Europe Stands Strong we
have seen it again at the end of last
year after after almost 10 years of
divisive debates we have an agreement on
the new pact on migration and Asylum and
I want to thank all of you in this
Parliament who have never stopped
seeking common ground and of course I
count on you and your final green light
before the end of this
mandate and the PCT isn't the only
critical step that our Union has taken
in the recent
weeks the hearts of millions of
ukrainians were filled with joy and hope
when we announced the opening of
accession
negotiations the people of Ukraine have
fought hard to achieve this goal not
only on the battlefield but also through
the work of their Democratic
institutions it's just in a matter of a
few months that they have passed new
laws to expand National minor minority
rights to improve the judicial system to
ensure checks and balances on Power and
last week the Rada approved in first
reading the lobbying bill that will curb
the power of oligarchs these are
significant
achievements Ukraine's Democratic
institutions are delivering not only on
our recommendation but on the
aspirations of their people a whole
nation is showing us just how much
Europe means to them and I'm proud that
our Union has answered Ukraine's
call now we must follow up on the
political situation and decision that we
took at the European
Council in preparation for the accession
talks we're starting the screening
process and putting together now the
negotiation
framework and in the meantime we will
also start working on our reforms our
own reforms to prepare for a union of 30
plus member
states at the last European Council we
also agreed to launch accession
negotiations with mova and with bosnan
and heroa when the necessary criteria
are met we have granted candidate status
to Georgia and we have confirmed our
Collective commitment to the Future
where all six Western Balan partners are
part of our
Union how will a union of 30 plus
countries work in practice only we
inside the European Union can answer
this question this house has already put
forward bold ideas for reform of our
treaties next month the commission will
set out our ideas in a communication to
the European Parliament and the council
ahead of the leaders disc discussion
organized by the Belgian
presidency honorable members the last
European Council has shown the political
will to stand with Ukraine for as long
as it takes but we must back this
decision with adequate funding we have
proposed to guarantee stable and
substantial financing to Ukraine over
the next four years to support the daily
functioning of the state to stabilize
the economy to bring it closer to our
Union all this requires an updated EU
budget and as you all know the midterm
review is not only about Ukraine it is
about competitiveness it is about
migration it is about our support for
the Western Balkans it is about
solidarity when natural disasters hit
like floodings or
wildfires these are priority ities that
we collectively share and we need this
midterm review and I am confident that
we will find a solution by 27 that this
is
possible the final topic I would like to
address is Hungary and its access to EU
funds this is also about the fundamental
values that bring us together when we
took office we promised to safeguard the
rule of law in our Union while being
fair to all member states I have made
this a priority for my commission this
is why the this commission has created
the annual rule of law
report and we have used all the
instruments available to us to protect
both the values and the eu's financial
institutions our goal has always been to
push for reforms in the member states
that they can improve the life of every
European last May Hungary passed a new
law on Justice Reform that addresses a
number of our recommendations from the
2022 report it is a law that strengthens
judicial Independence and limits the
possibility of political interference in
the
Judiciary this was required for Hungary
to meet the conditions for cohesion
funds
this is what we requested and this is
what Hungary delivered Commissioners
briefed Parliament beforehand and of
course they stand ready to provide
further information
anytime at the same time around 20
billion euros remain Frozen they are
suspended for reasons that include
concerns on lgbtiq rights academic
freedom and Asylum rights
some are blocked under the
conditionality mechanism and they will
remain blocked until Hungary fulfills
all the necessary
conditions in the meantime Hungary has
also received pre financing under rep
power like any other member State this
pre-financing is not subject to any
condition these are the rules we have
all agreed to them and we will follow
them this is what makes the rule of law
stand out from arbitrary power thank
you thank you very much and now we start
with the speakers for all the political
groups starting with the chair of the EP
group Manfred
V Madame President of parliament
commission presidency I will start with
a quote from my former Bel